let's go to mike from massachusetts
you're on the air
oh hey david can you hear me yes i can
uh long time listener first time caller
uh
also obviously from my title from
massachusetts happy to have someone from
my home state doing what you do pleasure
pleasure um i guess my question is a
little bit it's a couple years out
before this is a real concern but
um for the 2024 election obviously a lot
can happen between now and then
but as things stand right now there is a
real possibility that if trump uh were
to run he could win yes correct
absolutely so there's i believe there's
an argument to be made that trump's
attempt to overturn the election in 2020
really came down to a handful or maybe a
half a dozen or so people that
blocked him at key steps that would have
given him huge
uh opportunities to actually achieve
what he was trying to do
given like the increase of like
self-described mega candidates that
we've seen running for various state
positions and theoretic and whatnot and
you know with trump having the
popularity that he has and most likely
going to keep that popularity over the
next three years or so if trump were to
run and theoretically lose
do you see a possibility where he could
actually pull off what he tried in 2020
or theoretically if he ran and won
could he then install enough people into
key positions that he could actually
completely change the system when even
after he's gone
republicans could run the whole run the
show regardless of what the votes are
you know the latter one seems
far-fetched i don't know that 80 plus
year old trump
as president in an even more kind of
dazed and confused state than he was in
during his first four years
is really going to do that i i think
that that's kind of far-fetched my i
think the first concern you mentioned is
a more legitimate one which is it's
looking good for republicans in the
house in 2022 on redistricting alone
never mind actually flipping seats
um it's looking okay for republicans in
either 22 or 24 taking control back of
the senate i don't know that biden gets
re-elected i don't know that if he bails
and kamala is the nominee that she wins
so by by january of 2025 you could again
have total republican control of the
white house house and senate and that's
really really
scary and uh even if they only have
control of some of those
could they
somehow use whatever resources they have
to give a win to trump even if he didn't
earn it in the way they fell short of in
2020. i don't want to be hyperbolic but
i also don't want to write it off i
think there are real concerns about if
trump loyalists control more
governorships the house and senate in 24
and if trump narrowly loses in 2024
that there is a lot that motivated
trumpist elected officials could try in
order to put trump in the white house
even though he didn't win do i think
they would succeed
i still think they probably wouldn't but
the fact that we're even talking about
it in these terms is very scary
that's fair um
to my somebody to my latter point i
guess i'd ask it's not so much to
trump's benefit but if he were to win in
2024 yeah and let's say like you said
republicans control the house control
the senate could they now that they've
seen how close they can get to actually
overturning an election could they spend
that term the 2024-2028
setting things up so they can
essentially run the show going down the
road even when trump goes away they
could try yes i think i think you're
that's a much more plausible way which
is it's not about trump per se it's
really about others
laying further groundwork and that was
more of my question it's not even a
conspiracy theory in the sense that
they've been doing it with voter id for
15 years they've been
this is what they do they do it with
redistricting so of course they would
continue to try and find new ways
okay that was my question the first time
around i guess i didn't articulate that
quite right but no problem i appreciate
that my pleasure i appreciate the call
all right have a good one i'm sure i'll
be calling back again soon all right
there's mike from massachusetts let's go
next to jamie from canada jamie from
canada you're on the air
hey david how's it going it's going well
thank you um i was just wondering
how do you
think the that biden's agenda is going
because we've had basically the endless
frontier act which passed the senate
surprisingly did not pass that hasn't
passed the house yet then he has the
american rescue plan which which he
signed into law and then he just signed
the bipartisan infrastructure into law
but
so that's like he's hidden three so far
but
technically but he also has the the john
lewis voting rights act and then the for
the people actor the the right to vote
act or whatever they're calling it now i
was just wondering um so he has about
maybe six or seven pieces of legislation
on his agenda what realistically uh what
do you think we're going to see
being passed
oh it's such a tough question because
you
candidates make way more promises than
they can ever
keep or make a reality
um
at the same time you also had
biden dealing with covid and the delta
wave
and i've expressed disappointment that
more hadn't been done
um
my expectation is that maybe not by the
end of this year but by the end of the
first quarter of next year there will be
some additional major accomplishment by
joe biden i don't know if it'll be the
buildback better spending bill or if it
will be something else including items
you mentioned
but i think that the way i would say it
is biden's doing okay on getting some
things done
although it's starting to feel a little
bit light we had the covet stimulus
vaccination rollout now we have a much
smaller infrastructure build and
initially proposed signed i think in
order to get back to like a b he needs
one more big piece of legislation by the
end of march of next year that's kind of
my mindset right now
uh-huh and he said i i think he said
this but he said i'm gonna use every
trick in my book to try to get this
voting rights um passed
and he said i'm putting camella in
charge and um
uh i was just wondering what you thought
of that
yeah i am
unsure
as to whether the vice president
um can get it done i mean there's no way
to sugarcoat it i i hope that she can
i'm unsure and so far
she
does not have major accomplishments
under her belt but that's you know it's
just i'm not saying it as a criticism
it's just she just doesn't right now and
she's not particularly popular right now
i hope that she can do it i don't know
if she can
that's fine um one last thing before i
go is that my realistic expectations
my my over performing hope expectations
for the senate and in 2022 is 54 56
democrats but i know realistically we
might get only 52 or or maybe just hold
the 50.
let's just hope republicans don't take
over i'm setting my sights much lower
than you
yeah yeah
because people are telling me you got to
lower your expectations you gotta think
it's just gonna be 50 or 51 dens i think
i think cautious optimism is the way to
go i appreciate the call and
yes thank you hope you have a nice day
and canada is really nice it is a little
bit chilly i love canada we love canada
here thank you jamie from canada very
much appreciate the call